88-year-old Rian Opel has relied on
medication to help him breede since he
was two moving from New Delhi India's
congested Capital to a suburb on the
outskirts of the city hasn't helped he
develops intermittent cough which at
times intensifies that we have to uh we
have to put him on intensive
therapy tens of thousands of Indians
many of them children like Rian suffer
from asthma pneumonia and other
respiratory diseases caused by pollution
when the cold weather sets in they crowd
hospital emergency
rooms the air quality starts
deteriorating from November when Farmers
burn crop stubble ahead of the new
planting
season adding to emissions of vehicle
exhaust fumes and dust from construction
sites the result is a toxic mix one that
is killing hundreds of thousands I as a
chess surgeon now rarely see a normal
pink lung even in nonsmokers so that's a
huge change in the color of an organ of
people that I as a chest surgeon have
been witnessed to in the last 35 years
of my career and this is primarily due
to pollution because if a nonsmoker
develops black deposits in the lungs it
can only be because of the air the very
poor reading of the air quality means
pollution levels are more than 25 times
the World Health organization's
recommended limit environmental
activists say the government needs to
address all contributing factors action
needs to be year round action especially
on sources that are present within the
city whether it be construction dust
whether it be biomass burning whether it
be transport emissions and Industrial
emissions all of these require sustained
yearround action recent Studies have
shown that exposure to pollution over a
long period can cause high blood
pressure and significantly increase the
risk of diabetes authorities have tried
to regulate crop burning and have
imposed restrictions to control vehicle
emissions but scientists say more
decisive action is needed to protect the
health of millions of people in one of
the most polluted cities in the world
Min Fernandez Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer